why would you bet on goliath when we got
bet david valuetainment giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we gain no value to haters how they run
homie look what i become i'm the i'm the
one
[Music]
i'm one of those people
cnn we're going to be laughing thank you
all right so this is episode 181 tom
trying to be a comedian folks forgive us
but uh
so it's been an interesting morning so
far you know we've been talking about
who's have who uh which uh talent was
the best at acapella
vinnie tried to hit a an ariana grande
you kind of hit a little bit right from
her being live with the weekend
last year at the vma give us a little
yeah
okay
tom how beautiful is that what a way to
wait time almost cried he almost cried
um mariah carey gang we
we decided today to do a podcast for a
couple reasons because if we don't do
today we've been not doing it for
a while consistently because of travel
but today we're just going to hit some
of the stories yesterday we had uh
uh
on which was phenomenal we had a great
time with him but today we're going to
cover some stories let me tell you what
stories we're going to be talking about
uh number oh here's a story about
billboards in san francisco and la
warning people
against moving to texas by invoking mass
shootings i can't wait to talk about
that story right there with you
tom's got a bunch of stuff to say about
student loan uh with forgiveness with
joe biden
some commentary on what former clinton
advisers had to say slamming biden
student loan bernie sanders even wasn't
impressed by dave ramsey wasn't
impressed by so we'll talk about that
uh we will talk about the 3.8 million
renters likely to be evicted in the next
two months that's a real number 3.8
million people likely to be evicted
there's a talks of a
civil war right now from both sides but
a big part of it is you know lincoln
project rick wilson warns a civil war is
coming if it hasn't already
uh arrived cnn saying we're trying
really hard to be less of a democratic
mouthpiece good for them for saying that
less of yeah less electric bill
skyrocket crippling low-income families
with no end in sight i saw an article
that said
in norway right now to to fully charge a
tesla to fully charge a tesla
costs a hundred dollars to fully charge
a tesla thanks electricity okay to fully
charge it honestly i'm pissed off a guy
right now we all are about it and then
in l.a it costs that to fully fill an
escalade yeah like regular gas
that's the point so the point is the
point is so if they're pushing that way
the cost isn't really going to be that
big of a savings we'll talk about that
british household energy bill to jump to
eighty percent
to over four thousand dollars a year
we're going to have paul sankey who's an
expert in oil energy he'll jump on from
uk to comment on that here in a few
minutes california is pushing the hold
gas-powered cars to be banned by 2035
even if a republican governor gets a uh
uh wins uh the state that's still going
to be happening and then obviously a
bunch of different stories that we can
be talking about and mickey mantle card
sales for 12.6 million dollars and if
there's any other topics you want us to
talk about put it on super chat
uh we will possibly address it if you
put it on super chat let's get right
into it okay so tom student loan debt
i'm going to read these stories and you
tell me your thoughts on the student
loan debt that we got going on the
forgiveness program that we have going
on
um let's see which story okay so former
clinton advisor slams biden student loan
debt handout this is terrible
policy
well it's bad policy as well as bad
politics for that amount of money you
could find free uh pre-k
for every three and four-year-old for
ten years you can do a lot more good for
poor people
communities of color and underprivileged
by doing pre-k you could forgive all
medical debt which unlike student debt
is not free enter freely entered into
former advisor clinton said paul begla
said that
paul begalis said adding that he was a
progressive what is my party doing with
this they're disadvantaging
i think they're not helping the people
we're here to help which is poor people
in underprivileged communities and
they're not helping their politicians
who are running
uh begala said this so at the same time
bernie sanders i'll give you what bernie
said about this
bernie said uh uh on sunday responded to
examples of democrat criticizing
uh half a trillion dollar student loan
that hand that by saying the criticism
is correct before arguing that the
answer is not to deny help to people who
cannot deal with these uh horrendous
student debt maybe we should have the
courage to take on the drug companies
and not pay 10 times more for a
particular drug
than they do in other countries so the
answer is not to do what republicans
want to do oh it's unfair to this person
because we're helping that person the
answer is maybe to create government
which works for all people and not just
the wealthy campaign contributors that's
what bernie sanders had to say tom what
are your thoughts on this student that
forgiveness well i'll tell you i don't
normally line up
the way i line up right now with paul
magella but i am a hundred percent with
him there are upstream problems in this
country and there are downstream
problems
the student debt that is in the hands of
these students that are being really
hammered by the processors remember it's
the loan processors once you get the
student loan debt you get a letter from
somebody that say hi we are the
companies going to be processing your
debt send your payments here and the
interest rates and everything that go
with that the students get hammered by
that that's downstream if you want to go
back upstream paul bugala is doing a
great job of making a point is saying
listen want to help education and get
people more educated we could take all
this and we could cover pre-k and three
or four-year-olds so we could start
education an earlier year and give kids
that are normally disadvantaged a jump
start maybe
to be you know more competitive later i
love that line but the other side of it
that that i'm looking at is bernie is
right
what they're doing here is forgiving the
people who knowingly went into the debt
now i happen to think
what we should probably be doing is
working on a relief with the processors
what if we took
one tenth of that half a trillion
dollars and bought down the interest
rate with the processors so that people
have a fighting chance to pay off the
debt says hey you owe 80 000 to the
processor currently it's sitting at nine
and a half wham it's four now it's four
percent you know as well as i do adam
just the this the math of money that
would be a huge help on the interest
rates out of things that's exactly right
so rather than forgiving the debt why
don't we get into it and say how do we
make it more manageable for these people
to pay off and something else i'd love
to talk about pbd on another time
if the oil companies raise prices and
they get drug into congress for price
gouging hearings
guess what the entire
collegiate system needs to be dragged in
front of congress
for price gouging hearings yeah so
my angle is a different angle by the way
and and i i appreciate that tyler can
you show the video i just sent you i
don't know if you have it or not so this
is a father going up to elizabeth warren
do we comment on this yet or not i have
no idea okay so so elizabeth warren's
talking to a bunch of folks
and his father on the day when they
announced this walks up to elizabeth
warren and says this and she has nothing
to say like elizabeth warren's helper
cannot wait for this man to stop talking
you'll see this if you can make it
bigger so everybody can see it go ahead
and play it and let's see let's hear the
audio watch this and then she says
something
uh
fast forward a little bit like three
seconds oh he's waiting for him okay
right there watch this yep this guy in
the blackjack listen my daughter's
getting out of school i saved all my
money she doesn't have any student loans
am i going to get my money back
so you're going to pay for people who
didn't save any money and those of us
who did the right thing get screwed now
it's time
bought a car went on vacations i saved
my money
he made more than i did but i worked a
double shift worked extra like dollars
works he was 10. so you're laughing
yeah that's exactly what you're doing we
did the right thing and we get screwed i
appreciate it
yeah
i love those moments so so you know so
you can't blame people like that who are
sitting there saying i did all the right
thing but you're going this direction
and then what i will say kind of where
tom was briefly commenting on it is the
following thing here's what we have to
ask ourselves okay
so in the process in in this context of
student loan what parties are involved
let's go through it number one is the
loaner
the loaner is who sallie mae sally made
number the end number two is who is the
person that's receiving
the debt which is who the individual
customer student the customer student
possibly which parent right
okay so we got the loner which is sallie
mae and
navient okay then we have the person
that's getting the loan which is the
student
hence the parent then we have government
and then we have college okay so you
have four parties involved here now
let's take a look at this when they do
this
who
doesn't pay a single price for this by
the way we have one other person
involved in this as well it's called
taxpayers okay yeah so we got taxpayers
which is us we got the student that got
the loan we got the sallie mae who was
like [ __ ] here you go and then we have
the government and then we have the
university who paid the least price when
this decision was made out of exactly
the universe is exactly business raising
price exactly and you know what you know
what's crazy about that this part that's
crazy about that when you're talking
about universities
universities
themselves you know are sitting there
uh they keep the money and eighty
percent they said the other day for
every one conservative professor in
america there's 13 liberal professors in
america so they have a monopoly on
philosophies they're teaching to our
students that are being centered so
there is already a monopoly of teaching
a philosophy that you have a control
over you're not getting a
six professors on one side six on
another side or six six and one
independent and you're kind of learning
from everybody and then on top of that
part
that we're talking about with schooling
they have the audacity to bash
capitalists who pay taxes
who go through what they go through and
you're not paying any taxes
and at the same time you're not even
being punished the punishment's going on
students no one's judging you for your
quality of education where salaries
haven't increased for the last 20 years
maybe you want to be judged a little bit
if education is so fantastic about how
how are kids coming out with the same
average salary as they got 20 years ago
you want to blame corporations how about
we blame your method of education how
come we can't hold them accountable how
come nobody can get at them and say hey
no no no you can't talk about this
because i went to such-and-such school
and i'm a booster god forbid we say
anything about this university so that
part is not being accountable so then go
to the next one
and let's find out who pays the biggest
price so the person that pays the least
price and this party is who university
university who pays the biggest price
the tax customer the customer which is
the student the parents their parents
who's the second that pays the biggest
price
taxpayer it's us it's us okay because
we're in the backstop when you forgive
it you got it so there's two left
government and salami which lets you say
it's the least
they're there so the person that pays
the biggest price is the student second
is us the taxpayer least is colleges
then it's sallie mae and the government
what are we talking about and it's not
what we're talking about here it's not
to feel bad about but there is a party
in this the loan processors who are now
going to be processing less loans so
they're going to make less money so as a
business the loan processors are going
to have their business hit look
it's hard to feel bad for those
particular folks the biggest question is
the following question okay
what can you and i go
and get financing from the bank
for like house car so we can get a house
the bank will bank a a finance will uh
uh a house house a car will they finance
a car of course will they finance a
wedding
no why not
because there's no it's going to fail
way too much
so they will not finance a wedding okay
let's keep going with this will they
finance me
uh potentially starting a business maybe
at best you're right maybe at best well
but only to the extent you'll sign a
personal guarantee against your outset
right if you even have this motorcycle
motorcycle i got a motorcycle how about
an art piece of art if i'm getting will
they finance a piece of art i don't
think so
the bigger banks goldman morgan they
will do it i don't know if the bank of
america guy hey kpbs can you find us
trying to buy the salmon monday or
whatever but it's usually half a value
but she's like half value yeah now
here's the last one you ready how many
banks finance me to go get a four-year
college zero why not that one weird why
are we the feds the bank of the state
let me get this straight banks won't
finance weddings at college
way too risky yeah right
maybe there is a lesson there because
what capitalism and free enterprise will
teach us is whatever people are not
willing to pay for there's a reason for
it okay there's a reason for it what are
your thoughts with this story here well
look um there's sort of mixed
i have mixed kind of feelings here i'm
not a fan of this believe me the guy
that went up to elizabeth warren here
who said i saved that money you're never
going to hear me disagree with that yeah
100 okay that is my entire slogan of my
entire life is save that money so
respect to that guy double shift exactly
so but there is a difference between the
elizabeth warren bernie sanders wing of
the
progressive left and the
biden side of things because they all
campaigned on different promises so
everyone will talk about promises made
promises kept
biden campaigned on cancelling ten
thousand dollars of student loan debt
whether you agree with that or disagree
with that that's a different topic
that's what he campaigned on elizabeth
warren and bernie wanted to cancel all
debt
and everyone was like yeah that's a
little freaking aggressive bro so
there's 20 million americans who woke up
this week and said i owe exactly
zero dollars now if you're that person
the choice is yours now buddy you've
been given a life raft you somehow woke
up you had twenty thousand dollars of
student loan debt depending on your uh
pell grant status right tom the pell
grant yep that's if you're a lower
income the whole mechanism and
and i think 40 americans have
received some sort of loan forgiveness
so
i'm not a fan of this i had d1 on my
show the sauce cast last week this guy
got famous viral for doing a song called
i paid sally maybach where it was a play
on words between rather than driving a
maybach because he's a rapper he paid
sally maybe that's actually pretty dope
and it was ridiculous it went viral and
the guy hit the scene so i'm not a fan
of this but this is what biden did
promise
my next point and then i'll turn it back
over to you guys
the fact that paul
my like how my whole save that money
political uh wokeness whatever you
wanted like awakening it actually
happened at a um insurance event that
you've ever been to aalu i know what it
is okay there but we met at now but
years ago and alu and now actually
merged it's an area called finseka now
right
and this is
20
10 20 12-ish
and they had a debate you talk about
this is your idea of what you want
school to look like they had a debate
and who was the debate with
paul begala clinton guy and none other
than
tucker carlson
fox guy so i'm sitting there listening i
have no political ideology at this point
i'm just watching tucker and paul pagala
go at it i'm like i like this [ __ ] yeah
this is good i ideology's exchanged left
right up down i'm like okay he's got a
point he's got a point he's got a point
but circling back making my point here
this is something that tucker and paul
pagala would both agree on they do they
they do not like this idea yeah all this
time i'm pissed off packages i mean we
both joined the military about the same
age now i'm pissed off because i didn't
go to college i didn't spend no now i'm
just like what now i have to pay for
other people's kids to [ __ ] go to
college and it drives me bananas and i
love that you said you said a good good
saying monopoly have a monopoly on
philosophy it's what they want to teach
and that's it yes by the way i'm i'm
right now like you know this whole thing
about
um
okay so a few things
teachers who are being forced to teach
what they don't believe in they're
leaving and finding other jobs
parents who are having kids go to school
being forced to learn something that
they shouldn't learn
they're deciding to listen honey you
better get a second job you better drive
uber at night our kids are going to a
private school so that's number two so
public stakeholders or they're voting on
the arizona voucher program which is so
hot perfect that's another round of
taking so so we have those two three you
got uh uh individuals who are now being
uh asked to become teachers who are not
fully qualified to become teachers they
went to school you got the philosophies
being forced down their throat this this
is this is great let me explain to why
this is fantastic for me because this is
going to force people
uh to say okay this is what you want to
do no problem here's a route i'm going
to be taking if you think you're going
to be forcing more people to have the
philosophy of handouts you're going to
piss more and more and more people off
yesterday who's our uh biden's uh press
secretary what's her name uh karine
jean-pierre karin john pierre's being
asked about you know so you're okay with
uh kids you're okay with uh uh of
immigrants crossing the illegal
immigrants crossing the border without
being vaccinated you're not even
checking them but you're worried about
you know novak you know coming to a u.s
open to play tennis yeah he says and you
know did you hear her answer i heard it
did you hear what happened her answer
was well we are not allowed to talk
about private medical situations of
people that are coming oh yeah i'm like
wait what how did you spin that one i
was so impressed about it she's good she
did that's their job though just spin
job but but that's listen spin is on
both sides but that spin was like you're
a goat of spinning right there
to do something like that so you know
but people are starting to sit around
and say if you live by the border you're
going to be like look man these people
are coming left and right and i don't
feel safe right now some people that are
coming over some people are gonna sit
here they're democrats they voted for
this they're like what the hell is this
i busted my ass i'm not a democrat
because i want high taxes i'm a democrat
because i agree with let's just say a
person is a pro-choice or i'm a democrat
because i'm you know a social safety net
but i'm not okay with this bro what are
you doing i'm a working democrat so
they're creating enemies yeah to the
point
i love it we're a guy
who got americans to accept marijuana
through a podcast there was a netflix
down where he was the main guy on this
netflix show
joe rogan got people to say maybe weed
isn't that bad
he tells aaron rodgers
possibly a top five best quarterback of
all time
the solution is to vote republican yeah
what the hell are we talking about right
and elon musk says that here's a point
when when sometimes you're winning you
have blind spots you think you can
really manipulate everybody san
francisco voters you know what they said
yesterday san francisco people that live
in san francisco i'm not paying taxes
until you clean up the [ __ ]
people in san francisco are saying i am
not paying taxes until you clean up this
homelessness problem these are democrats
that voted for those policies and the
needles it's slow yeah
what you said about uh it's novak right
novak djokovic
if he spells n-o-v-a-s no yeah
novak's he can't fly into the country to
play a tennis game but the border and
why doesn't he find a way to get to the
mexican border cross through there
that would be so funny he's coming
back
he's huge well all he has to do is take
a boat or just get air drop and just
walk through the border i mean he
doesn't have to be vectoring that's so
funny and he whips out his phone in san
diego gets an uber boom yeah and he's
there like this and like how did you get
here
but indeed it is quite offensive that
they're still demanding this is it new
york state is it is it uh the us open
specifically who is this nfl still they
don't they're not messing around he's
obviously anybody coming over here to
play any sport or anything no he he
cannot play and he's top two in the
world i think number one number one
right now
he's one of the three goats the three
goats of tennis who's the open sponsored
by the advisor that's right oh weird go
figure right i don't even know really
isn't that weird
isn't that weird you know there's
another level of hypocrisy that's here
with the student loans and if you think
about it in the united states government
you have medicare right how many people
have a person in their life on medicare
your dad my mom your dad right my mom
yeah your mom excuse me um and they can
tell you hey i went in and i was gonna
have a chest x-ray the doctor said 260
dollars
and he gets the thing back from
nope the rate for an x-ray is 181
dollars ever see that so you the doctor
bill is augmented but our parents don't
pay the difference the doctor accepts
the 181 yeah it's the same thing for
dental
the only exception on federal
programs
is sallie mae and education they don't
they don't adjust the price they're and
all of what sallie mae would have to do
is say i'm sorry the maximum per credit
hour we will pay is this
because that's how they do it in health
insurance that's how they do it in
dental care and that's how they do it in
the private sector that's how they do it
in the public sector
with medicare
they determine that within a certain
bound is the price sallie mae is the
only place and higher education is the
only one to get a get out of jail free
card yeah we're going to raise it 20
this year oh okay well then we'll just
put that on the loan here that's the
only place that happens yeah the you
know they keep accusing biden of playing
politics you're just playing politics
you're just well that's his job that's
exactly politics kind of a politician so
he is pandering to his base he obviously
he wants to sure up the gen z vote let's
say or the millennial vote and this is a
ploy or a tactic to get them to say you
know what brian's actually doing
something for me you're right so do i
agree with paying off student loans no
but do i understand the philosophy of
why he's doing it i get it because it
doesn't make an inflate time it's making
inflation
higher isn't it because we're
we're dumping more money sure there's a
part of the student loans that you could
argue we're never going to be paid back
you know our history major who's never
going to be making more than 30 grand a
year or something and they're probably
never going to be able to pay back part
of their student loan which is another
discussion right
what what are you underwriting stem or
you're underwriting liberal arts
are you um
what percentage of uh
college degrees are just completely
useless in your opinion i don't know if
we have enough time for them
i would say there's a lot of it but i
look at it this way
pbd what if we made a simple
valuetainment public service
announcement commercial
banker sits across from student
yeah i'd like 80 000 20 a year
to state college but i'm getting a
degree in art history well great um
i'm looking here at the um
jobs and what an art history maker will
make
and um i can't underwrite this why
because according to this it would take
you 40 years to pay it back
if you
still kept the student loan payment
higher than your rent or your house
payment eventually
oh and put this awareness out there do
you see what i mean yeah it's it would
be an underwriting and it's not the
banker being bad the bankers simply say
i can't underwrite that
i can't underwrite this transaction but
what if you go excuse me though joe
biden's president now he promised that
he's gonna forgive so does that
does that sway my like can i get it he
said 20 grand is gonna be gone will you
give me the loan well if 20 years from
now the u.s president forgives half of
it and that's sort of a guarantee for
the bank then the bank could build that
in and underwrite it but yeah tom you
actually bring up a great point here i
know you were kind of being a realist
but also a little bit sarcastic i don't
know if people got tom's humor he was
kind of imagining but you do have a good
point here and the point that i think
you were making is what's the roi on
your investment in yourself and that's
what somebody who is 18 has to figure
out and that's
most 18 year olds could not tell you
what roi is but when you go to college
you're investing in yourself and your
future
income right you're getting a a degree
that will hopefully put you in a better
position to make more money in your
lifetime and yeah when you're 18 years
old it's a very difficult decision to
make all right what do you want to do
the rest of your life you're like bro
i'm just trying to [ __ ] get laid
on everybody well there's a that's a
difficult situation to figure out
i don't scam what no it's a four-year
social experience that's the truth
that's it there kids are not going to
get a better degree and solidify their
future you ask 10 kids i guarantee you
trying to hook up seven out of 10 kids
say i'm going for the experience i'm
willing i'm going to meet friends i'm
going to have a good job well that's a
good side if a person's if a person is
going for the social experience i'm
willing to bet you're going to party 10
times harder in the military than you
would if you want to go 1 000. i'm
willing to bet that uniform is going to
get you a hundred times more
where the
this is the piece to take it off and go
to the mall
you go to the changing room and gap and
yeah
it's either asu or fsu or san diego
state san diego state yeah it's what
you're saying that just sent them i
what kind of a precedent does this set
right
so we're teaching these kids that you
can take out 80 grand 100 grand 120 000
in debt and we're going to forgive it no
no no no no
10 to 20 000 so let's get the number you
can't
i would bet that they're going to keep
pushing to forgive more and more and
more of it okay but what's the next
elizabeth warren yeah by the way you you
can't be naive to think this is not
going to continue
like
you know people are about to get another
1600 check i think times two whatever
the number is going to be again this is
five years ago we would have been like
what are you doing where are you where
are they doing that though what do you
mean i think california is doing it i
think several states
first of all i don't support that i mean
either i'm not one that's sitting there
saying do that i've never been a part of
this uh ubi uh concept that's becoming a
norm everywhere i'm having a
conversation with andrew yeah i'm a fan
of that i'm not the only time if you're
gonna shut down restaurants
that is my way of making money
you i'm not in business because of you
you so you if you tell me i can't go to
work dude you better pay my bills that's
a different story yeah that's a
different story but for you to just send
out money
so if you're going back to tyler i want
you to finish your thought going back to
tyler
they're not gonna just do 10 20 thou
wait till two years from now they're
gonna say this should work do it again
and again and again but then where do
they go next
housing they they claim housing is a
human right so they're going to forgive
your housing are they going to give
their loan forgive the loan you take out
on a house and this okay this is
completely unconstitutional nancy pelosi
is on camera saying joe biden does not
have the power to do this the congress
controls the purse okay so you think
he's going to stop at colleges of course
not that's proved by the senate by the
way right so i watched this video with a
guy i think his name was uh p
peterborough david maybe oh patrick
every dollar guaranteed in student loans
the price goes up by 60 cents so what
are they going to do after this they're
going to keep raising the price raising
the price raising the price raising the
price raising the price katya has a
question too because i'm i'm not that
bright in this field
who are they how far back are these
loans getting forget like who's how far
does it go back how many people how many
people they're giving these these loans
to
your currency
everybody that owns i think
up like meaning
starting next year
you're not being forgiven but everybody
will probably oh wow that's a lot of
current current people you know the
total that it came out to be all this
money 500 billion dollars 300 billion
300 billion which used which used to be
a large number but now every single bill
and anything that happens this is a
trillion
300 billion is a lot of it a lot of
money i
it used to be it used to be a lot of
money not using the nuclear-powered
printing press that we have over the
department of treasury now yeah it's
it's pretty pathetic what's going on
with this okay so let's continue to the
next story were you trying to finish up
with something there tyler
oh no this is just a set uh uh
ten thousand dollars in federal student
debt per per borrower and twenty
thousand for pell grants uh less than
125 thousand dollars so i imagine
anybody who has outstanding student debt
will be given ten thousand dollars
forgiven excuse me forgiven ten thousand
dollars god did that answer question for
you yeah so you have to take you call
your like people accountants that's the
number right there okay billboards in
san francisco and los angeles warn
against moving to texas by invoking
mass shooting
by invoking mass shooting i don't even
know if this is legal to do that like it
can you really do something like this as
a
campaign but let's let's read this okay
so
this is a new york post store if you can
put up the picture so people can't see
it mysterious new billboards
are warning california residents not to
move to texas as record numbers of
residents flee the soft on crime golden
state for better
quality of life in red states the texas
miracle died in uvalde don't move to
texas that's actually the billboard
just look at that right there
the texas miracle died in uvalde don't
move to texas the billboard reads
alongside a hooded figure and a crossed
out don't mess with texas slogan the
texas miracle refers to former governor
rick perry's description of the state's
regulatory model which helped it weather
the great recession don't mess with
texas a favorite motto in the lone star
state is rooted in the 1980s
anti-littering
campaign when you see something like
this tom what do you think about
i think that if you and i put a
billboard up going the other way we
would be picketed we would be canceled
we would be attacked can you imagine if
we went the other way
point one point two
this is boogie man politics you have
nothing good to say about yourself so
just point and say ew
and that
and that's all they're doing it's
they're trying to get you to stay
to stay in something
bad
by making something else look better
yeah exactly
not saying hey here's what we're going
to do for californians this is what
we're doing for business opportunity for
education is going to do for error
that's what we do for highways nope adam
do you have thoughts on this yeah of
course yeah of course i mean we you know
obviously uvalde is the hot topic right
now but you know mass shootings are not
unfortunately anything new in this
country but you know politically you
might have to have a short memory to not
find the irony here because not too long
ago in 2015
there was a san bernardino shooting a
mass killing right mass shooting where i
think a dozen people died yeah
right when you play politics like this
just be careful what comes out on the
other side now i'm not sure if you saw
what gavin newsom has been saying his
political ads have you seen any of these
lately so um
i went down the rabbit hole and i did
you see uh um ron desantis's air force
ad top gov okay top gov sick okay a
little little
hokey to me a little cringy and i was
like all right cool you got he put his
kid in there i get it all right and then
i saw gavin
gavin newsom's ad
and i just like threw up in my mouth i'm
not a california guy i don't give two
shits about gavin newsom but i just know
like what's a decent ad what's not i
gave like
the uh ron desantis had like a c minus
and then i saw the gavin newsome ad and
i think it was on july 4th and i was
like how do people not feel the fakeness
oh god of this guy i'm gonna read you
what he basically had to say and you
just let me know what you he says uh
it's independence day and i mean when i
talk about as like
suit as like just phony and fake ha it's
independence day so let's talk about
what's going on here in america freedom
is under attack
in your state right republican leaders
they're banning books they're making it
harder to vote restricting speech in
your classrooms even criminalizing women
and doctors i urge all of you living in
florida and i was like hey i'm living in
florida what you got going on here buddy
i want you to join the fight and join us
in california where we still believe in
freedom i'm thinking god how out of
touch
is this freaking guy he's gone and how
does he keep getting elected and his
voice we have to do the batman yeah
it's just you've seen uh what's it uh
american psycho with christian bale yeah
that is gavin newsom to me that that is
and here's a guy who's never had a real
job here's a guy that's never had to
work a single day in his life in a free
market in this you know enterprise site
to see how tough it is and making
decisions for them and uh
annoying a bunch of different people but
i will tell you what i think about this
ad here's what i think about this ad i
love it
i love it
let me tell you why
do you remember about six podcasts ago
when i said if i was if i was the
governor of florida
i would say the following
if you want great entitlement programs
to move to california
if you want
to have your kids
have the ability to get the medicine to
have sex change you know whatever
transgender if you want that move to the
following states california mm-hmm if
you want
to get in town
if you want to if you want move to
california i love it you know why i love
it there's a part of me that's using
humor and sarcasm to almost make your
point it's not even used in humor it's
straight up facts so for them to do this
i love it because if a person like me
who's sitting there
and that's my state i'm gonna say what
the hell is this guy talking about i
don't relate to you i gotta go find a
new state to take my family where i feel
safe and quite frankly i don't feel safe
yes and i got a text from jedidiah she
was in new york guy
i'm sure she had a great time and she
didn't recognize that
difference
and she says
within nine hours while she was in new
york okay
she saw two crimes right in front of her
okay
she encountered a man walking around
naked creepy man walking around naked
okay that's why vinnie and i go to new
york and then he says she says i want to
know where adam went when he visited and
did you guys have him blindfolded
so maybe jeff if you see something say
something maybe next time you guys got
to go to new york together
i feel like if you're looking for
something you're going to find it i walk
miles around new york i freaking love
new york but if you're like if you're
looking to find something weird in new
york believe me you'll find it well did
you hear what the new york governor said
about republicans kathy hokel what did
she say did you hear what she said
republicans aren't welcome here get on a
bus and go down republicans aren't
welcome here get on a bus and go to
florida bye and they
by the way and they criticize us for
living in an echo chamber apparently the
right has this giant echo chamber that
they can't get out of apparently she
doesn't have a spreadsheet because
that's going to increase the deficit in
her listen talk all the smack you want
about gavin newsom don't get it twisted
this guy is a front-runner for the
democratic i don't disagree he will be
running
and he could very well win did you did
you see him uh uh in the interview when
he's like i'm telling you i'm not
running i don't know what other way to
tell you i am a governor i love this
state then the guy says then why are you
talking about all these national issues
well because that's important i love
this country this is my country's yeah
but you sound like you're running i'm
not running can you say right on camera
you're not gonna be running i'm not
gonna be running for i'm telling you i'm
not it was a very
the interviewer did a fantastic job
pushing him on it to the point where he
was getting pissed so by the end of it
if you watched it
you would have said he's not running i
posted on the instagram post this means
he's running because he's obviously do
you think gavin newsom will end up
running
uh i'm for president i'm saying seventy
percent oh i'm way higher than that i
was gonna say because the last time i
was on here you showed that he was he
was uh with the shirt white shirt tie
walking in the white house lawn while
biden was and the only reason i said 70
is because when i was in california
somebody shared with me some things
about him
that is spreading that is why he doesn't
want to run because he doesn't want that
to come out okay now
how much credibility that has i don't
know anything the person that said it
has credibility but the person that told
him i don't know that person so it's
like adam telling me his best friend
said this but i don't know who's best so
without him without him running let's
say gavin newsom yeah who
biden says he's going to run who do you
guys think is going to be who would be
their frontrunner if newsom because i
think newsome is the presidential look
that they would go for
yeah according to favorability ratings
it's bernie bernie sanders unless unless
hillary gets involved just because i
think the democratic field is wide open
right now yeah wide open
i'll go back to the same point i made uh
10 podcasts ago
the dnc
is shadowing
all of these stories that are coming out
on biden and you have the soft negative
story in the new york times in vanity
fair all these on biden is it time
you know and it's like the it's like
is it time to say goodbye to good old
joe is that it you see all those soft
articles every week there's a new one
yeah there's articles that aren't even
that soft they're just like time to go
joe yeah bye-bye grandpa that's cnn did
that msnbc did that so as soon as
the dnc behind closed doors
clicks the stopwatch it starts
that's where the money is the money to
run a national campaign is with the dnc
coffers
that is the soros money that's the big
stacks
you have to raise campaign money but the
big gunpowder is with the dnc so the dnc
has not yet said
we are going to primary this president
but when they do
it is a wide field
but bernie gavin and they're all going
to have the same thing well
we got together as a political party and
it's too important and this is too
important so i am running because it's
too important and that's what they'll do
once they
have a solution
for
the biden step aside and they're going
to do it elegantly but until that time
he is the
pin cushion
that all of this controversy attracts
and so let him take all the heat on this
why put a front runner out there and let
them get beat up a little bit right now
right you wait till after midterms if i
was at dnc
this is exactly the way i'd be playing
it hmm
i just if i was burning though right now
i'd be like you guys
screwed me over how many times i'm not
doing this [ __ ] again
i don't think i don't see bernie running
just because just because the dnc is
done with bernie doesn't mean the people
are done with bernie yeah true but
that's correct people the people still
want bernie but
i don't know when he talks his upper lip
that's that you know that's bernie
sanders right the huh
doesn't look this doesn't talk he talks
like this and this lip doesn't move
that's actually
[Music]
as long as this is numb like you went to
the dentist
like you got numbed up that's good can
you do it
that really
he just congested all the time
can we play that i don't know i don't
know if we can or not
jamie foxx killed him
but but whose podcast is that before you
played whose podcast is that
is it that's somebody's podcast some
compliment now don't play don't play
don't play but what do you think about
death row snoop deal double g great guy
yeah jimmy fox just let's talk about the
economy let's talk about the economy
different take on the u.s economy maybe
it's it isn't really shrinking world a
wall street journal
economic output can be measured two
different ways gross domestic product or
gross domestic income for every dollar
an individual spends to buy some good or
service a restaurant meal a car a
doctor's visit another individual earns
a dollar of income to make and deliver
that good or service gdp captures the
spending side of these transactions gdi
is the income side some economists look
for clearer picture by averaging gdp and
gdi the average measure of output barely
moved at all
rising at a 0.2 annual rate adjusted for
inflation over the uh first six months
of the year this is more consistent with
a stalling economy than one in recession
what are your thoughts on that tom well
okay
my car was stalling
and it comes to a stop
right versus recession it's it's sort of
like i'm saying
right sort of like they're saying
it's not horrible it's only terrible
yeah you know that's awesome you're
you're being too hard on us it's not
horrible it's merely terrible it's not a
category five hurricane it's only a
category three meanwhile almost got hit
by a cow flying by yeah right
so i i think this is this is spin this
is pure
spin so some economists look for a
clearer picture
by averaging so this is nothing more in
the white house saying hey we don't like
two quarters the two-quarter rule is
outdated that's a measurement we don't
like we don't want to call it a
recession because we don't want to
measure and that's probably an outdated
measure remember that two weeks ago
and so
they're trying to find
every spin they can because bill clinton
was right it's the economy stupid
james carville
well i think it was james carfield that
said that tom come on come on
know your people now tom he wrote the
script but bill delivered it beautifully
that's right it was correct and as we go
into the midterms it's the economy
stupid and what's going on here is make
sure media is complicit and trying to
find every way to
sort of spin and to say that a category
five hurricane is not as bad as a
category three
yeah but what is tom what do you think
about the fact that the journal wrote
this like that that kind of surprised me
it seemed a little out of step for the
journal i could see this from cnbc or
washington post or what have you but it
does seem a little out of step that the
journal would publish this actually a
great point by tyler why do you say out
of step though
because i think i find the job but real
quick do you find them to be credible or
not credible
yeah okay and that's my point is that
they they seem to cut through the
nonsense and the spin and i agree the
facts i don't i don't think they're
particularly one-sided i think if
anything maybe they're center-right i
think their own body they are definitely
center-right i think they're owned by uh
murdoch's group if i'm not mistaken um
his media group but typically they cut
through the nonsense in the spin and it
seems this seems a little out of step
and
it's just off
you're ultimately saying that you don't
agree with tom and you'd like to have a
debate with him now on the facts right
now i think what he's saying is why is
wall street journal saying the market is
not as bad where they're supposed to be
their position ought to be more of
we are in recession rather no we're not
really in a recession so i think that's
what tyler's saying it's a great
question um
kramer i think was yesterday or the day
before they said
if the the this trend is showing that
the market's going to come back up by
the end of the year it's going to be a
big uptick on the market by the end i
don't know if you saw that or not what
kramer said yesterday
about the market the reality right now
is
no one really knows what's gonna happen
okay no one really knows what's gonna
happen there's way too many
charts that you're looking at that are
going one side or the other side
but you you you have to look at a couple
things uh one of the one is the next
story that's coming up right now which
i'm reading to you 3.8 million renters
will likely be evicted in the next two
months that's a lot of people tyler
three point two
million right as pandemic eviction
moratoriums expire and rent payment
relief programs and across the u.s a
rental crisis is beginning to crest
about 8.5 million people are behind on
rent
as of end of august that's a lot of
people to be behind on rent according to
census bureau data of those renters
around 3.8 million say they are somewhat
or very likely to be evicted over the
next two months meanwhile rent continues
to tick up and top that 2 000 a month in
june for the first time on record on
record before the pandemic rents have
increased by almost 25 and 15
in just the past year according to
zillow evictions are spiking in major
cities across the country as well in
tampa florida evictions were
52 above average in august according to
the eviction lab at princeton university
in houston they were 90 percent above
average and in minneapolis st paul they
were 94 above average so
there's different worlds people live in
the world wall street journal maybe more
lives in their audience are earners
their audience are people that are
making money and
i would love to see the average reader
of a wall street journal like many
people may read l.a times
new york times new york post usa today
you know all that stuff but the person
that reads one like i've given wall
street journal to a couple of our guys
and i said look my suggestion is for you
to read wall street journal and they'll
read and they're like
the hell are they talking about what i
don't understand this don't like but but
that's why you already read the sports
section you ought to read it to see
what's going on with this so
they are talking to their audience
that's in this world and those guys are
probably not going to be affected as
much yeah okay we need an average income
is bad for somebody that's a wall street
reader i would say the average income
earner reading wall street journal's 200
grand i was going to say 150 to 200
grand yeah you think it's that high i
think i think it's 150 to 200. wow that
is the one percent or the top i mean
i think it's 10 by the way you know
to make the six figures is 20 okay yeah
so top 10 percent is around 150 200 i
think it's top 10 yeah that's about the
number yeah so i think that's their
readership and they're speaking to their
audience but yeah this
3.8 million evictions this
94 in st you know saint paul or 90 in
houston or you know the numbers like
this
american people are feeling it yeah just
go to the streets and ask them how do
you feel about what's going on with your
finances so they'll tell you this is
main street to your point wall street
journal puts together something says if
you take these two statistics and you
put them together like this and look at
this perhaps it looks like this okay
great meanwhile on main street
guess what the party's over and this
goes back two years ago the deeper story
behind this
pat this goes back two years ago when
remember when the federal government
prevented evictions cdc moratorium and
states prevented evictions everybody's
saying wait does the cdc even have the
authority to prevent me from evicting
somebody here in atlanta and apparently
they did
so this goes back this goes back two
years i'll give you a crazy story here
i'll give you a crazy story here
a person
who
made
little less than a million dollars last
year
made good money last year
we get an email and the email is
she would like to be the director of hr
for
valuetainment and i'm like wait what
yes
how why
i know where you live you live in a
beautiful place in one of these
high rises i know what car you picked me
up when we were going and doing the loan
paperwork
you told me how you did the last three
four or five years
director of hr is not a you know a
salary that's going to pay you anything
like
you know it's one tenth of what you made
last year is what you're going to get
paid for salary like that
why are you applying
the industry is so dry right now it's
not even funny wow okay
lols right now in america are not
getting hit five percent 10 or 20
percent
they're destroyed tyler when i say
destroyed i'm talking 90 percent dry you
know what 90 is let me give you a pain a
picture for you hear what this means
imagine you run a mcdonald's every day
to your mcdonald's 500 people come in
i'm just giving you a number
what would happen to that mcdonald's if
they went from 500 customers coming in
two take 90 only 50 people coming in so
what what happens to that quiznos what
happens to that jeffy lube what happens
to that movie theater what happens to
that restaurant what
90
of lo's income is gone
where is that felt
a card that sold for 1.75 million
dollars kobe bryant card
last year black label rookie card you
know what you just sold for on auction
last week
8.50 in one year it went down 50
who was buying collectible cards crypto
guys mortgage guys real estate guys you
have to know that
that is felt okay period there is no
wall street journal can write an article
like that and say the fact that it's not
really a recession it's more like a
stagnation or more like a flat whatever
no problem we haven't experienced
foreclosure yet it ain't gonna happen
for another six months well it's that
was my next question what do you think
happens to foreclosures after these 3.8
million renters get evicted so the 3.8
million renters get evicted they can't
pay the landlord who owns the house the
landlord who owns the house has no money
coming in how is he going to afford that
second home that he's renting out do you
see do you see foreclosure spike dude do
the house that we we look we just looked
at a place do you remember the place we
looked at yes so we went in the balcony
where i looked the view was incredible
the view was incredible
so we went out first moving into
what would you say about this building
what would you say about this building
the most elite building in all of miami
okay and the place we looked at can you
tell give them a visual tour of what
this place looked like oh that's um
number one it's
i mean can i say how much the apartment
this is this is a house or a building
this is the penthouse of the penthouse
of a 54th floor
your elevator move comes up to the floor
i'm thinking about buying this place the
entire place is 10 000 square feet
swimming pool on the 56th floor i mean
it's that kind of a place we're going to
put parties entertain all so i want to
buy this place and i want to and i said
i want to see this place yeah i text him
i got the realtor the next day we go
look at this place
yeah boom boom so we'll go look at this
place
and the realtor says uh well they had on
the market for 33 million dollars just
last year yeah but it's on a deal right
now for 26.9 million i was going to say
it was listed at 26. it's a building
where all the who's who's in miami live
in this building like you say the names
they live in this building and i'm
saying names won't say they live in this
building okay
so i look at the realtor what do i tell
the realtor at the end i'm going to make
an offer and it might offend you
she says don't offend me i said i'm
going to make an offensive offer
no no but but i said i'm going to make
i'm gonna make an offer and it may
offend you but here's the thing this
thing's not gonna sell right for the
number that they want but i have cash
i'll cut you check but i'm gonna make an
offer that's gonna offend you you know
you're gonna sell this for 30 million
dollars in the next five years exactly
five years i get to benefit for being
prepared taking the reason
and you take a hit because you sat on it
trying to sell it for a high price so
those are the situations where you see
the top earner all of a sudden having to
go from trying to sell it for 32 last
year he's probably gonna end up selling
you for less than half of last year okay
so these things that you read about it's
great for papers it's great to get the
stock broker or the hedge fund manager
to talk to his clients and say did you
see what the wall street journal said
today they said it's not as bad as you
okay let's put another five million
dollars into the market today but in
reality
the street the real people that are
doing what they're doing it's being held
can i can i say something to that point
because i actually did a man on the
street of how expensive is it to live
and rent in new york city i did that and
i've also done it in miami now if tyler
ever gets around to posting it maybe you
guys will see it but
the um but the point is
like in miami
people feel
rent has skyrocketed 40 in the last 24
months yep 40
okay so if you were paying 2 grand what
is that now 3 200 what's the what's the
number on that right there yeah so
people like the p like i completely
agree with what you're saying
about the wall street journal the top 10
20 of americans are reading that maybe
10
the rest of americans are just running
around being like how the hell am i
going to afford this rent increase but
the flip side of it is if you've saved
up and if you've been
saving that money
you might be uh looking forward to a dip
in the in the housing market
so my situation because you know i've
been here for like three months at this
point i have to leave the sub leasing
place that i'm at so i have to get an
apartment really really quick and
they're renting like this it's an
apartment complex by the beach all day
by the sea she goes you have to be out
of here by november first because that's
when the snowboard season what are they
called
seasons she goes because your two
thousand dollar twenty one hundred
dollar rent yeah he's gonna go up to
three thousand dollars and she's like
they're all gonna they can't get no they
literally kick everybody out yeah and
everybody's coming here that's not
intelligible here in south florida that
is very common yeah so pat what was your
cover first yeah what they're saying
november for me so what would you say to
somebody that's been waiting
yeah tick tock that's waiting for
remember i talked about this last time
for everything for the market to crash
and we're waiting for that moment
because i'm gonna have to obviously
lease again but you would say what six
months to a year would be somewhere
especially as a veteran va loan i'd be
able to get a loan and
oh i i you're saying like if one is a
good time to buy for me for somebody
like me pet that that has the loan i
could i would wait six to twelve months
yeah
i would wait six to twelve months
because yep i think uh uh
look just think about this guy that sold
this mickey mantle card for 12.6 million
dollars new record just so you know new
record you know how much he would have
gone if he sold it a year ago no joke 15
million no he would have gone through 20
million bucks
a year ago he would have done 20 million
bucks i'm not even kidding with you he
got 12.6 but he would have gone 20
million bucks okay why did he sell now
why didn't he wait to sell a year from
now because a year from that he gets 9.8
million bucks yeah
if not yeah because it's it's not and by
the way still 12.6 million or a baseball
card yeah okay and whoever bought it
good for them they got the fourth best
card in the world is what they got right
but
he sold now he's sitting there saying i
should have sold it a year ago and i
watched this i sold my wayne gretzky
card and i got 1.29 million dollars it
was a world record yeah you know when i
sold that card i sold it once ago two
years you could have waited another six
twelve months you would have an another
car yes seven months later sold for
three point seven five million exactly
no no no
how much will that card sell for now but
that card today will sell for two
million bucks exactly okay okay so the
the point is the point is like trying to
time everything you i mean i'm
i've been a victim of it on both sides
you're trying to get lucky not trying to
get lucky but i'm gonna say six to six
to twelve months maybe a better time but
this is not the time do me a big favor
just if i'm in the office just walk by
and slap me behind that and go now
yeah well let me know it's not just
rents right like obviously we're gonna
have paul sankey on later so i don't
want to get too far into this but but
political insider 20 million americans
have fallen behind on their utility
bills okay uh
uh texans have paid uh 50 more electric
bills so it's electricity it's energy
it's food it's groceries it's everything
it's across the board man people are
getting absolutely slammed how can
meanwhile we're sending billions and
billions of dollars back to ukraine
we're paying people off we're passing
360 million dollars to fight climate
change we're paying off student loans
like it's well there's an article
there's an article that you guys have
that's saying that the military is under
arm now we don't have that many bullets
because we've sent so many to freaking
ukraine not like we're going to get into
some [ __ ] let's go into that story
because that is a true story isn't that
insane that we're running out of u.s
military running low on ammo after
arming ukraine pentagon officials are
concerned that the u.s ammunition stocks
donated to ukraine have severely
depleted u.s stocks
weakening u.s readiness in the event of
conflict the wall street journal
reported monday the biden administration
has drawn much of the 13 billion in
weapon systems and accompanying
ammunition the us has provided to
ukraine from existing arsenals according
to the wall street journal while the
department of defense has declined to
disclose the number of ammunition rounds
in storage at the beginning of 2022
before the war in ukraine began it has
taken few steps to replenish depleting
stocks sparking worries that the u.s may
not have the ammunition it needs to
uh for its own protection the level of
155 millimeter combat rounds filed fired
by
uh howitzer weapon system in u.s
stockpiles has become uncomfortably
lower u.s pentagon official told wall
street journal the uss sent 806 000
rounds
of the 100-pound explosive to ukraine as
of august 24th it's not at the level we
would like to go into combat the defense
official told wall street journal
uh uh uh supplied howitzer have extended
you uh used for ukrainian forces some of
the foxes okay so there you have it that
was the story what you were talking
about i would say
why don't we go to afghanistan and get
what we left behind but i mean we never
borrow it back from al-qaeda because now
they're you know taliban
whatever hey potatoes tomatoes whatever
potatoes potatoes tomatoes
by the way for people that don't know
your background when you were in the air
force you were working at a nuclear why
don't you tell everybody what you were i
was uh stationed at mountain stream air
force base montana nuclear missile base
i was a flight security controller and
truck whenever i was on shift i was in
charge of 10 10 missiles that had up to
five warheads on each missile so i was
the guy that would
authenticate the guys going the missile
ears the launchers authenticate them to
go downstairs they're the ones that get
the codes they're the ones that could
launch we had um 200 missiles at my base
that from what i heard from one of these
guys we could have blown up the world
like 20 30 times over and i'm like why
do we have so much it's just it's insane
but but i saw pacquiao sometimes i
worked security where they'd open up the
rail and mind you 18 year old airmen
down there
working on a nuke and you look down and
you see it and it was just it was just
insane year old 18 year old kid just
like this hey give me a sandwich oh my
god but it was scary and then and then
they just told me because i you know i
had to have you know secret clearance
but and he was like listen we have a
couple of these bases that's nothing he
goes 80 of our arsenal is just in the
water just swimming around and all these
subs so if [ __ ] never pops i mean that's
why these rounds it ain't that important
because we got other we got other stuff
that we could use you know yeah if you
uh if you want to sleep easy tonight
know that vinnie o'shanna is had his
hand on the nuclear button at any given
moment
i couldn't go near the button but i was
making sure that they could okay what i
mean i want to know who you bribed to
get the clearance
no no oh you want to trip out you want
to trip out so i'm on leave i go home to
see my mom and my dad and everybody and
my my
fifth grade math teacher mr bonaparte
because you know when you get the
clearance they're asking people he sees
me in the mall he's like hey oh shawn
he's a huge huge big a buff guy he goes
dude you never what are you doing in the
military i was like what do you mean
he's like somebody in the from the
government called me and said and i
quote
does that he seem like the type of kid
that would grow up to do something
terrorist like [ __ ] to the country and
he was like no he was you know giving
people's wedgies and climbing up trees
and [ __ ] but no he wouldn't like blow
people up they're like all right thank
you click and that exactly fifth grade
teacher fifth grade math teacher said
that somebody called them and asked them
if i'll if i turn into to be a maniac i
mean i am a maniac but yeah that would
never hurt the country so
thank you for your service right okay
i wish i was recruited by the the guy
that was here the ci agent i'd be a
great cia
come on
i don't think you could blend in well
enough what are you nuts i'm a comedian
i'm out there i work here
he said the key is to not not be noticed
you are yeah
the person here that could is rob
yeah oh yeah for sure rob could be yeah
if there's anything that you should know
about rob gargiulo not noticeable not at
all is he even is he here but by the way
but here's a good news sitting right
here's good news even though we are
depleting in all this weapon good news
we have 87 000 irs agents which is
they'll save us yes which is fine and
they they know how to use a gun yeah you
saw them you saw how they were that
video was sold for you that is a great
callback we have commodity
safe about this entire situation it's
not going to work so we'll put them
right on the front lines the average
american really knew what we've got yeah
they build their mind yeah lasers so
let's let's skip
the
by the way the real
the real pitbull of the emir of the
world
military is the american navy and most
people don't know it and they think well
wait a minute you get the ship out there
get hit by a missile and everything you
have no idea the umbrella protections
over those ships
and you have no idea about the nuclear
subs and what they're doing down
underneath
but norad yeah norad is scary the stuff
that's under south dakota and montana
specifically and remember ellsworth air
force base elsewhere where all the b-52s
were and then tom daschle tried to close
it yep and then the voters closed his
career and they were done exactly that's
right that's been yeah
yeah yeah there's one there's minot air
force base there's one in um wisconsin
there's do we got nuclear bases well not
just that i think you could take the
american people can take some solace in
the fact that that the united states
government as as much as it's bloated
and
um
unefficient and those kinds of things
like you see you know it costs 94
billion dollars for nasa to produce a
rocket etc etc the us military produced
and built and designed a
sixth generation
uh airplane complete with ai like in
under a year brand new airplane brand
new airflame all new electronics all new
ai basically flies itself all in under a
year like we we if we want to do
something we can do it we still have the
best engineers in the world we still
have the best factories in the world
like we still can do these things but
the va forget it i went to the va it was
the worst experience of my life because
i tore my legs let me read you guys a
washington post story that some i think
your your parents and my parents may
like
uh missouri misery a
school district revives paddling to
disciplined students misery school
district i like my mom my mom right now
is like yeah there must be a lot of
middle easterners
a school district in southwest missouri
is bringing back a measure it last
resorted to over two decades ago to
address disciplinary moments a problem
spanking students classed classes
started monday for 1900 students in
in cassville
uh a school district about an hour west
of branson and some 15 miles from the
arkansas border during open house
families were notified that the school
board had adopted a policy in june
allowing use of physical force as a
method of correcting student behavior
parents were handed forms to specify
what oh my god that's not right is this
real
yes
this is washington post story this is
known as
child
formerly known as corporal punishment
the disciplinary measure you usually
involve striking students on the
buttocks
with a wooden paddle
a teacher or principal must send a
report to the superintendent explaining
the reasoning behind the punishment i'll
bet you anything those kids are going to
get better grades they're not going to
skip school and their future like do a
percentage of how good those kids are
going to be in college and those kids
are going to be amazing bro because
that's what's like to me society has
gone down the tube i'm actually by the
way if you're watching this if you're
watching him do poll
already okay i want to see what the look
at this if you look at the cartoon if
you're if you're if you're like this is
a good idea give a thumbs up if you say
this is a terrible idea give a thumbs
down i'm actually curious okay so by the
way as a parent what do you think about
this
giving the green light a little spanky
spank
what do you think
you know what
i'm cool with it without within certain
standards i'm cool with it you're cool
with it because no one's going to spank
your daughters okay because they're good
kids i'm concerned
tom you're okay with le let's just
give a hypothetical
bailey acts up in his class one day and
the
teacher hits her bailey is 16 i think
you need to dive into this and see that
okay okay so bro second grade or under
okay so when they were kids let's not it
when if when brooke was
seven years old 10 years old you'd be
okay with the teacher hitting them no no
no no this is
this is like
five six year old what have you read
okay go to it let's see what age but the
point is would you be okay with it if
they were younger within standards yeah
you'd be okay with the teacher hitting
your kids wow not me sure it's not
hitting the kid they find it different
they're invoking a spanking
dude i'm telling you speaking what's the
difference so what what's going
spanking is a spank on your butt dude
that that's what that's what's wrong
with society is because nobody gets
spanked anymore i don't know
listen i'm old enough to remember i
remember i was in i think second grade
at the time i remember teachers would
pull your ears yes and bring you up to
the front of the classroom by your
earlobe
i'm like what the [ __ ] is happening
right now you're not my mom and teachers
would do that that's unheard of we had
in fifth grade they had a board of
education and they were on a board like
a paddle and yeah you know why we stayed
in line because we didn't want to get
hit i'm dead serious i did crazy [ __ ]
but i stayed in line because i know that
they hit me
that they'd hit me and then they called
my mom and they're like i've got in
trouble they'd call my mom my my walk
home she'd be in the balcony and i she
had that middle eastern
look but pvd this is what dylan's age
shout out to you somebody just did a
super chat 20 bucks now you're going to
user's name is big daddy brown 9. big
daddy brown 9 gave 20 bucks incredible
for this 20 bucks and he says the only
person who gets to paddle me is adam
[Laughter]
nice shout out done for 20 bucks 20
bucks 20 minutes a day that's that's it
right there no but like listen i i for
us it was a ruler between your fingers
and they squeeze wow
what does that mean ruler between your
fingers and they squeeze it like this
guys
okay and then it was take your shoes off
and socks off and lift one of your feet
up they would hold it and they would hit
it with a ruler on the bottom of the
this is in iran this is an iran i mean
this is a whole let's go to america here
for a second yeah well hold on i'm
surprised they didn't like well you know
misery
yeah better you understand
but that's what it was and you and i'm
actually not joking with you that's what
it was in iran okay so look how you
turned out so i'm actually shocked it
wasn't way worse
when i grew up i had friends that went
to catholic school and they used to talk
about the nuns with the forearms and a
tattoo of an anchor yeah you know like
popeye yeah i was like man sister mary
watch out yeah she's crazy she's she's
like
sister mayor they talked about it you
know it's
it's like i was failing penmanship of
course
we just had our friend the priest on
recently so i mean these people are they
go without uh
getting their rocks off so this is like
you know s m for them these uh sisters
and fathers don't go there
you think i'm going in there they went
the church went there buddy the church
don't defend the church guys the church
there they went there i can't comment on
the church and i don't know who's there
what are you big tech tom he's
restricting my freedom by the way alex
patino just said wow
while growing up in mexico during the
90s my teachers used to hit us with big
wooden rulers not only being pulled by
ear also but by the hair and growing
beside your ear or fist
close hit on the head wow and i bet you
he has a great job he's a good person
he's a good person he's a good person
and pays his taxes you know every every
grandpa right now that tells the story
of the wooden paddle with the holes in
it the tape wrapped around the handle is
going to work
they're complaining about the the
generation how bad the youth are they're
going you're going to get a scene are
you assuming around the closet right now
trying to fight it there it is if a kid
gets hit in school they'll turn out to
be a better kid i i think and this is my
opinion again
the generation that i was in and i think
up to one or two after mine we got
disciplined we didn't get i hate when
people still be i never got beaten i got
hit and i heard those words wait until
your father comes home that [ __ ]
instilled fear and we knew stay in
certain line yeah
i went a little bit to the right went a
little bit left but knowing that there's
a consequence for your action that's why
everything's so [ __ ] up right now
sorry for my french because now like
when you back in the day when your
parent was like don't touch this and you
kind of went close like ah you know not
to do it now kids are like what are you
gonna do call the [ __ ] cup i own you
because you can't even touch me now they
send you to the principal and they
suspend you for three days and the kid's
going awesome yeah i don't have to go to
school yeah exactly that so when you
knew pat like when your dad was going to
hit you you didn't do it i mean you you
skirted around it there's no discipline
now there's no you can't even talk to
them because their feelings are
protected more than anything you know
there was a part of this that used to be
in in boot camp in the military that
they used to do is they got away with it
because it was abuse you know there
there was this also in military a lot
they have you're also 18 20 years old
and gradually they went away saying this
isn't healthy
uh you know i don't know i i i don't
know if
there's many ways to discipline your
kids many ways to discipline people many
ways to punish them
uh many ways so then the argument that
me comes if you're okay with this are
you also okay with the death penalty
like how do you feel about the death
penalty
i'm okay with it and certainly
yes for example give me which certain
instances
insider trading
[Music]
nancy pelosi pelosi and her husband what
like i was i told you nicholas cruz so
for instance any of these mass murderer
kids like the uvalde guy the parkland
like
off with his [ __ ] head i like okay
and potentially his family yeah oh i
remember we had that talk
i went there no pat you know what i
think i think if you've killed an
innocent person
or any of the time this is my opinion if
you've killed somebody and i love these
videos i think it should be implemented
if you've murdered one two i don't care
how many they put you like in that court
while you're handcuffed and the family
gets to have their way with you while
you're handcuffed for five minutes if
you live go to jail if you die you die
i would [ __ ] pay-per-view that's
totally okay with these you know my
brother you killed my mother uh we're
gonna beat your ass in court and if you
die that's it and we pay-per-view it
that's i'm actually okay with that
you're turning into a business model
which is interesting
you and tom
that's his blue ocean strategy
i'm okay with capital punishment you are
yep and i feel that the multi-level
appeal
um
in the u.s appellate courts and the
governor's stay
um
you know is very effective
when you execute an individual in most
u.s states
i think the number is
20 that there's been 20 not just a
motion in court but there's been
like 20 different um items of appeal
and it's part of our system the are you
sure
and then ultimately if the governor
agrees remember the governor's got the
last thing does he give him a stay of
execution if the governor doesn't then
we've reached the point and we're done
with it
so i
i'm okay with it and i think the system
works now people are going to say that
before dna evidence
innocent men
were executed and we have now found that
absolutely be correct i'm talking about
today
with all that we have
i'm okay with the death penalty in the
united states and the appellate system
and the governor's uh control
i'm okay with it
by the way let me read a couple comments
here step by step dvd in california gave
20 bucks in california instead of a
panel they use a finger is what he said
where's that finger going yeah
here's an example of misbehaved children
who had no discipline just look at all
the writers 2020 summer of love loot
okay
uh kpz kennedy kindergarten flushed a
stock down the toilet as a prank
got the belt from the principal 30 years
later i still i still believe he was
right interesting nice well you know
what everybody's saying right what's
that is that kids are going to get
paddled because they don't want to
transition
oh really that's what everybody in the
chat is so funny
they're going to get paddled because
they don't want to
i don't want to be a girl
shut up
uh today's audience got a sense of humor
so sense of humor okay so megan merkel
did you hear about making merkel's uh
comments she just she's she just figures
out a way to stay relevant which listen
respect to her as a marketer but megan
merkel hits a hits at british
media they call my children the n word
okay
megan merkel says she hated having to
share family photos with the british
media outlets whose readers called her
children the n word when she was an
active member of the royal family the
duchess of sussex was expected to
give pictures of her three-year-old son
archie to the royal rhoda the press pool
that covers queen elizabeth ii in her
line of succession why would i give the
very people that are calling my children
the n word a photo of my child before i
can share it with the people that love
my child
the suits alum who is a biracial asked
the bullying was almost unsurvivable
merkel uh told oprah winfrey in her
bombshell cbs interview uh revealing
that she experienced suicidal thoughts i
mean is there a proof pat that like i
want oh when stuff when i read stuff
like that show me the proof that readers
said called the the child and then i
mean dude don't get me wrong there's
hate and there's ignorant people out
there but like you said everything that
i ever read about heard something about
race or something about like bro you
just you're right like you're just not
relative nobody cares nobody cares you
know what this is not just some
anonymous person that threw it up on the
yeah
the daily star chat exactly exactly but
you had drunk people and
idiots and just disgusting individuals
that would do that but where was they
mainstream propagation exactly i agree
i'm with you benny brother this is like
lizzo at the vmas yeah accepting her
award right for the millions of people
claiming she's oppressed yeah she wants
she's you're number one you won the best
girl and then and you're and it's not
good enough it's not good enough
did you see mariah carey calling megan
merkel a diva and then she was asked uh
uh uh i think it's both a compliment and
a criticism carrie told the duchess
of sus you know 41 during the tuesday
august 30th episode of her uh podcast
where she's also diva but uh look to me
if there's a leaders bulletin of the
most annoying people in the world she's
on that list i think it's just simple if
there's a leader's bulletin for top 100
most annoying people in the world she's
in the top 100 list someone would put
her in the top 10. i'm just being
friendly why is she annoying to you
because when a person is so constantly
desperate to get attention and be
relevant in this manner
for doing what like what did you do to
get the attention that you're getting
okay
it's constant it's constant complaining
it's constant victimhood it's constant
oh poor me poor you you are treated
royally you went overnight nobody you
are royal nobody knew who you were the
night before then all of a sudden you
are who you are and you're acting like
you're above the average person you're
very annoying simple as that it's a very
annoying human being i've got a maybe a
different take on this because number
one let's just if anyone is using n word
like disgusting horrible no i don't give
a [ __ ] i don't care if it's meghan
merkel liz i don't care disgusting
like no i don't accept that whatsoever
now she told me as part of uh uh uh who
was the girl that was married to johnny
depp who's uh was
part of that okay but but okay so even
more so
you know who i put this on not on her i
put this on prince harry i don't
disagree okay so this is someone who's
you need to like talk about getting red
pill red pill community johnny depp or
even will smith
this is someone where prince harry
should have said listen this is my
family this is my lineage this is my
literal kingdom yeah i'm bringing you
into my world baby girl here's what you
can expect and you need to act
accordingly if not i'll go literally get
a million other women who will come in
and gladly marry a prince he made her a
successful
coming to america okay yeah shout out to
eddie murphy yeah but this is on prince
harry he should have kind of been more
manly and said listen baby you might
deal with some negativity you might deal
with some drama
act accordingly okay you're going to be
a freaking princess
how many other women are going to say
sure
whatever you want me to do buddy so on
one end i do understand that she's
annoying what have you but i do
understand like the negativity where
this kind of stems from but this is on
prince harry i agree i agree i think
it'll be easy princess no no you you're
right you're right on uh the situation
all i'm saying is if there's a leader's
bulletin she's on that leader's voice
i don't the media call her daughter the
n word the same way jessie smallett was
attacked in chicago
by two yeah white supremacists like this
is magic but you know what it is it
works it does it works because it's such
an easy card to use yeah i've been
called a lot of words
how many times have i been called a
terrorist as a joke i don't know 20
times can i tell you
you know what my reaction was when the
person was joking with me on that
i can't you know do i come out and say
when i was in the military my drill
sergeant one time joked and said this
about me and let me tell you it really
affected me i had some thoughts no no no
no no this isn't that's what was you
know but that to use it like that where
i feel sorry for oh my gosh that must
have been a very painful phase of your
your life okay it is what it is by the
way a couple people gave come some real
good commentary with super chats yimi
moreno said whatever happened to
in-school suspension then out of school
my friends and i hated in school
suspension back in the 90s interesting
this next one is actually very good
point michael klein when you force
students to wear masks
online schooling and other damaging
learning effects to children of course
they'll be unruly who really deserves
the paddling the students or the teacher
sure i don't disagree i would even say
more the ministry the administration
more than the teachers because the
teachers are just following the
huh the teachers might be into it
you never know
some of them maybe i don't follow them
maybe okay so
in about eight minutes we're going to
bring paul sankey and to see what's
going on with these gas prices and
oil and uk and you know talking about
how much it's costing to charge up a
uh tesla we'll get into that here in a
minute with the electric bills that's
happening as well
but uh mikhail gorbachev you know who
ended the cold war dies at the age of
92.
um when the award came out i think it's
yesterday when this happened yesterday
afternoon um
uh uh the man who ended the cold war war
uh without bloodshed but failed to
prevent the collapse of the soviet union
died on tuesday at the age of 92 russian
news agency cited hospital officials are
saying gorbachev was the last soviet
president forge arms reduction deal with
the united states in partnership with
the western powers to remove the iron
curtain that had divided europe since
world war ii and bring
about the reunification of germany what
are your thoughts on gorbachev what
memories do you have yeah i remember
being a kid in 1987 i was six seven
years old eight years old whatever i was
at that time and uh
ronald reagan president of the time 87
famous words
mr gorbachev tear down this wall and you
know what happened six months later
that's exactly what happened and uh that
was in 1987 that was the berlin wall
came down in 1990 mikhail gorbachev won
the nobel peace prize
and the whole methodology was he was
making relations with the west even
better fast forward what
30 years later you have vladimir putin
who talk about relations in the west
could it be any more different than it
was in 1987 1990 so you're talking about
the two
largest figures in recent russian
history mikhail gorbachev in the late
80s and putin of today and
wow have they've gone completely
different ways in russia so
the the i i'd i'd like to find out what
putin's reaction to his death is is
putin spitting on his grave they were
not fans of each other okay they were
not exactly fans of each other so
putin's reaction is it will be a
telltale sign of where russia is today
versus where it was in the late 80s
would you ask him what do you remember
what are your thoughts on him all i
remember is watching the movie uh naked
gun
grabbed him in a headlock rubbed his uh
birthmark and it goes away and he goes i
knew it
that is the funniest mikael gorbachev
because i i remember those little
moments in news in history but that was
so funny man leslie nielsen god rest
assault hilarious hats off r.i.p mikhail
gorbachev
because
in his senior years
he changed his mind and he made the
right decision and moved things forward
senior year what do you mean while he
was uh when he was at the time that he
greenlit the wall
um he was fairly entrenched in his
political career
but he got to that point he saw which
way the wind was blowing and he
glasnost is what it was called remember
that
was that trust but verify that i
remember that was like
that right yeah trust was verified right
and reagan you also also mentioned that
reykjavik getting back on the plane
gorbachev goes out there with his hands
at his side like this and he goes
what did you want me to say
and reagan turned to him and said you
should have said yes
because they were up there having the
salt talks
and gorbachev god bless him
changed his mind
and he
he went with it
um and so i
i have respect for that pat let me get
your opinion on this because that was
sort of the end of
communism right i mean the music who
knows where it's at today but when's the
last time a country was like all right
we're done with capitalism where it's
it's over i mean recent memory i don't
know venezuela i don't know where the
word that's but that was the end of the
ussr you have family from russia your
mom said yeah family i believe
okay
but i know you're obviously you grew up
with imperialism socialism communism now
you're a major capitalist how are you
processing all that so so so why why did
he do that why did he flip just think
about it why did he flip that's the real
question
why did he all of a sudden go from hey
you wear this everybody wears the same
shirt same clothes same food same car
same place they live we don't have any
competition people get a chance to spend
time together they're together communism
works karl marx was right
why did he switch why that's the
question everybody has to ask not what a
noble man who switched yes what a noble
man who finally made that decision but
why did he make that decision that's the
question we got to ask why did he
economically it just didn't have a
choice well no he did have a choice he
did have a choice here's what happened
there was a person
who was willing to spend one-on-one time
with him on multiple occasions to paint
a picture and learn about his world and
then teach him about the world that they
could have over there if he opens it up
where they can become a superpower
and had a very civil conversation with
him and eventually he said you know what
you make sense i hate to say it but you
do we have to switch he made the switch
and he helped his people out and that
man who persuaded him
was number 40 president that we had in
us his name is ronald reagan
so props to gorbachev for being open but
props to reagan for being able to build
a relationship with him
so he can be open to that idea the
approach that biden has taken with
uh uh putin if reagan would have taken
that approach with
uh gorbachev you think they would have
been open to the idea no there's there's
certain things about
how many things get done when you're
sitting with somebody kneecap to kneecap
and you sit down and you have a
conversation with them and they say look
why do you do what you do here's why i
do it listen here's what we do this is
what's working for us let me explain to
why you may want to consider doing this
for yourself there is a method to
communication and obviously reagan is
one of the better communicators uh we've
ever seen in our lifetime he did that so
there's power in that of course every
time anybody from the left or anybody
from the right sits down
with somebody that they shouldn't it's
very easy for the media to say what
they're best friends they're russia's
puppets they're you know cuba's puppets
they're whatever's you know it's like
very easy to do that but uh there's a
there's an art to getting enemies to say
okay you seem sincere let's talk about
it see what we can do about this so yeah
rest in peace gorbachev you know
obviously for me it goes more to rocky
iv
you know if he can change if i can
change anybody can change that whole
message rocky iv i've watched a few
hundred times
as a kid that's where the memory comes
in of how we were able to kind of figure
out a way it was a unified time method
you know as strange as it sounds
it was unified we're definitely not by
the way bingo i was gonna go this
direction and you beat me to it pop
culture played a major part of this
jordan peterson when he was here he said
you know what something about a 16 year
old wearing blue jeans and driving a
mustang you know it kind of puts the
wind at the in your sails when you're a
kid in russia and you're seeing what's
going on in in america and the pop
culture and everything that's happening
in the late 80s
it's like okay i kind of get i like that
vibe there's freedom in that
the russians have said no to any further
development and participation in
international space station is that
correct it's like three weeks ago
yeah yeah correct you're done with this
remember that started
with skylab and soyuz and they built
this contraption so they could dock them
together they built an adapter so it
would connect to both ships and they
connected them together
and we did experiments in space with
making primitive proteins and drugs
their symbolism there is what you're
saying yeah there's also pop culture
right because let's face it you're not
gonna make eight tons of drugs in space
you're you're testing things
in a weightless sterile environment but
the point was
the two superpowers and everybody's
worried about lasers from space and you
know um
reagan's star wars plan
and all that instead you know
at the time we got together in space
yeah and so there's little things like
that that went through you i agree with
you there was like a a little
togethering that was coming
he probably showed he probably reagan
probably showed him putting like a
a vhs of like the movie grease and was
like look how much fun they're having
you guys could have this too bro you
could have this the groper shop would
drink but that guy was a drinker like
he'd be i saw him with clinton once and
he was
drunk he drank bro i wish i was
introduced me to this wolf man
right yeah may he rest rest in peace
meanwhile uh uh
bill clinton was sitting next to a sex
therapist and they were having
conversations i think you saw that what
an impressive guy i mean you have to
know uh to be that ambitious at that age
to someone improve his game
it's your hero
out of any project you've seen the
picture 40 years
some people rethink and grow rich some
people read rich dad poor dad some
people read you know uh power versus
force bill clinton reads like you know
thinking grow sexual thinking you know
the stuff that he consumes is
he still has it yeah it's it's on a
whole different level
some people would would have called them
a in the 90s a top g maybe maybe he
would be like top g god by the way
that's a guy
you know
interesting what we haven't even
commented on the fact that he got uh
he got banned on every single social
media platform out of everywhere did you
have any comments on that on uh do i
have any comments on andrew tell us tell
us what happened with that i mean as
what's the question what do you think
about the fact that he got banned you
know he got i mean
i think it's disgusting i i've said this
before and this is maybe
i'll i'll make the analogy here
i lived in durham cove but i lived in
florida and texas
pretty open states okay so i didn't
didn't really affect my life per se
there was no any mandates this is what
you have to do
and not until i started to have you know
engaging conversations with good friends
of ours you know i'm thinking of in new
jersey in new york and in california you
know ricky what have you when i saw the
restrictiveness i was like oh [ __ ]
that's what it's like but it's almost
like the you know first they came after
the gypsies but i wasn't a gypsy so i
you know i didn't say anything and then
they came after the jews and i wasn't a
jew so you don't say anything if it's
not happening to you but as content
creators as someone that is in the
manosphere red pill space especially all
the people that i interview on the sauce
cast to see someone like tate get taken
down
it really messes with me because it's
like there's nothing he's saying
saying that i think
you should be limited of your freedom of
speech and i know that people are going
to say well youtube and tick tock and
instagram and meta they have the right
to do whatever they want to do their
content but like how far can this really
go i stand with tate rumble give him a
deal by the way he realized yeah yeah
rumble announced it uh
fight last week or something like that
that he's now producing content on
rumble
uh we're gonna see what's gonna happen
with this guy by the way did they ever
give an argument on why they did that
yeah
i've not heard of this i just i saw the
i saw the guideline of just
the groups or threats like what because
he's saying stuff that you don't like
doesn't fit your hat you're in touch
with tate what's your perspective on
this guy right now i mean i've i've said
i've said what i've said about tate i
think tate
you need like you know you need somebody
like that to give the argument and if
you disagree with them give a better
argument yeah but until you can't give a
better argument his argument makes sense
you know like a bernie sanders is
necessary so somebody says well maybe
you know he said such and such well
what's your argument
if you don't have a better rebuttal
maybe bernie's right what you do trump
does what's your argument against maybe
you have a better argument to rebuttal
what trump has to say maybe trump is
right maybe aoc is right maybe
candace owens is right may so everything
like people like this is necessary
for for for the opposition to want to
poke holes and say well this is why but
instead of saying do you know what he
did to his girl do you know what he did
to that listen if you want to play that
game do you know what oj did you know
what this person did you know what that
combinated do you know what putin's
still on twitter how come those guys are
not bad so that argument
loses credibility well the problem that
i have with this as someone who has been
more liberal in their philosophies is
the the classic definition of a liberal
is that you're willing to respect other
people's opinions that are different
from yours right you're willing to
tolerate and be tolerant of other
people's opinions what's happening now
with the progressive woke left big tech
what have you is you're just shutting
down voices you don't agree with
that to me is un-american
okay you might hate this guy think he's
misogynist disgusting
okay
but that's america baby hate on them all
you want but you don't cancel somebody
and that's the problem with what's going
on in society today is that people have
gone way too far extreme and they forgot
what being a liberal actually means it's
open to other people's perspective yeah
and i fallen victim to that tour i'm
just like this is the way it's supposed
to be that's how i think and you i
learned it from you when you were saying
i like to talk to communists i want to
talk because yo sometimes you can see
like oh [ __ ] i can see how you think
like that and how you adopted that idea
because yo every like you said nowadays
it's this is my lane if you don't see
this lane yeah you're a piece of [ __ ]
let me tell you let me tell you there's
certain people
that there's always a demand for
they're going to find a home this guy's
going to find a home he found it first
of all
every day rumble was sitting there
saying i'm begging you to cancel tate
yeah of course every day rumble was
hoping they canceled tate and they did
and now he's at rumble every day because
he gets to say
at rumble come do whatever you want to
talk about and let the audience decide
whether they like you or not and rumble
is right that's the same you know what's
crazy is that we had dinner with the ceo
and founder of rumble chris uh pavlovsky
yeah what how many months ago was that
three months ago five months ago yeah
and who was under fire at that point
john other than joe
and we had a dinner it was almost like a
strategy session which turned into a
strategy session where pat said you know
what you should do chris you should make
an offer of 200 million match the offer
that spotify gave
joe rogan throw it out there and see
what happens what did he end up doing he
did that two days he [ __ ] did it two
days later wow okay and obviously rogan
didn't go anywhere he's still on spotify
yeah but
kudos to him
by the way
there could also be a re one of the
reasons why spotify didn't do anything
because they knew if they did rumble
would have cut that check exactly so so
chris almost gave uh
rogan
spotify the position to be cornered to
say well we better keep this guy because
if not these billions of eyeballs are
going to go this is the whole premise of
what you talk about free market
capitalism is so good give me another
option here baby i love it mcdonald's
burger king starbucks
oh my god i love it okay all right
sounds good so anyway we should get in
touch with this guy tate maybe try to do
something with him sometimes eventually
we will we've been speaking with him
eventually we will and i think it'll be
a big hit but if we do it won't be a one
hour or two hour it should be like a
five five hours something like a
marathon where we talk
who knows maybe maybe some cigars maybe
some drinks locations yeah i don't know
guys if i don't get to go if this thing
happens i'm gonna be very upset oh god
if we do this meeting they don't allow
people that have nuclear clearance
by the way on a more exciting topic cnn
we're trying to really be less of a
democratic mouthpiece what what a story
here wait they're a democrat they let
they lean left the news and never
now under the warner discovery corporate
banner and let's sin spring by cnn
worldwide chairman chris lake is trying
to inject more balance into its program
and become less radioactive to
republicans how and whether that can be
accomplished remains a mystery cnn has
to figure out what it wants to be
said carol costello a former anchor
there and now a journalism instructor at
loyola mount uh marymount university
former president donald trump portrayed
cnn as an enemy and a new pew and a pew
research uh center study illustrated the
impact that had on his followers in 2014
pugh found that one-third of people who
identify or lean republican said they
distrusted cnn as a source of political
news by 2019 that number had shot up to
58 percent higher distrust than the new
york times by washington post msnbc if
you wanted cnn to gain back credibility
what would your feedback be to them if
you're sitting on their board what would
you say to them i think this is a move
that they need to do i don't respect
this guy chris lick coming in what was
the what was it jeff zucker who was the
former ceo of
cnn i look you know they
cnn i remember a time when cnn was
actually respected and credible
throughout the country the voice of
james earl jones this is cnn yeah they
were the most trusted name you know so
listen i
i i don't even watch cnn at this point
but listen stop i don't i watch your
house it's just yeah
that's not true you're like
every airport in
i
america
one person on cnn one person and i'll
stand by this the day i die i think
fareed zakaria is one of the smartest
people
on the planet fareed zakaria he's got a
show on sunday other than that
you know you could throw um jake tapper
and to be incredible wolf's potential
but credible but like this dude right
here what's his name again that just got
fired
brian stelter the don lemons of the
world when don lemon started crying that
on the day that biden won
it was like all right what happened to
real journalists
listen i can i can spend an hour talking
[ __ ] about fox here there's a difference
between real journalism and opinion
journalism and i'm okay with opinion
journalism but i believe that there
should be a disclaimer on the tv this is
my opinion yeah but the same thing goes
for hannity the same thing goes for
laura ingraham but don't pretend to be a
real journalist don lemon and then it'd
just be your opinion yeah but that's my
son what makes what makes uh uh tucker
carlson who's number one in television
different than any single one of these
people because i mean he's obviously
he's a republican but he's just saying
the facts and he's pointing out the
hypocrisy and the stupidity of the other
side but what makes him so loved and so
viewed because these guys are spewing
the same [ __ ] if you think about it i
mean he's just smarter than them but at
the same time the majority of what he's
doing is his opinion yes is he mixing in
facts and
and funny writing they don't quite
there's a reason that the opinions start
at like six and after and the real
journalism whether it's brett bear or
whoever's on it yeah four o'clock
caboodle
neil cavuto i love that guy on fox
charles payne oh that's legitimate i'm a
huge fan of kabuto
punch is great yeah i got i got one idea
not to cut you off adam i got one idea
pat to make to make cnn have a good
voice and have a good uh vision whoever
they hire to read the news can have
never voted not left not right not
democrat we don't want you to have voted
for [ __ ] because i just want the news
but i want you to be biased i don't want
you to have a different just tell me the
news raw and uncut and let me figure out
what i want to do pat i want to get your
opinion you have to actually respect
this move
okay what's the alternative just
doubling down on the left ideology or
just saying you know what let's go back
to what ted turner envisioned in the 80s
and let's just actually
just get closer to center and being a
credible source what are your thoughts
yeah i look you know when you come in a
a new owner buys a dying company okay
when a new owner comes in to buy dye
income there's a difference if you buy a
growing company a steady company a diet
company when you're buying a dining
company what's the first thing that goes
the ceo leadership yeah everybody first
person who fires a ceo then you go
through all the executive team and you
bring your team in it's the first thing
you're doing you do it that's part of
the deal that you do we're willing to
buy but you gotta go yeah that's like if
the ship is sinking the captain goes
first exactly and we're gonna ask you to
sit and do what whatever you're doing
here but you gotta go okay sounds good
so it's fair to say this is a sinking
ship is what it is okay cnn is according
to ratings you're absolutely right
ratings dollar
every possible way they're getting
destroyed right now okay so if you come
in what do you got to do well the
bottom's got to go don lemon has got to
go brian stelter has got to go he went
by the way this picture
if you can zoom in on the picture here
if you guys can do that by the way that
look at that picture right there cnn
heroes okay that guy's thirsty
that guy's 36 years old that's the thing
he does not look 36 no okay so so first
thing you got to do restructure
fire and then you got to bring some
fingers you got to bring some people
from the opposite side you got to bring
some people from the opposite side so
cnn
i if i'm really trying to make some
stuff work i mean i'll give you
something here they would never do it
but i'll give you some stuff here i'd go
up for tucker 40 million a year okay i
would do that wow i'd go off for tucker
a five year 200 million dollar contract
is what i would offer today if i'm
running cnn or you bring back like a
crossfire yeah i'm gonna go do that i'm
gonna go uh uh offer uh uh bill maher's
not leaving hbo because he's comfortable
where he's at but i'm gonna go get guys
that are gonna get eyeballs and they
have a following and they're fun i'm
gonna bring russell russell uh russell
bryant not russell russell brandt i'm
gonna bring kim i'm gonna go out there
and get
a younger hip audience that's getting
people to you know be on both sides of
the i'm gonna be on a recruiting spree
of getting people on both
sides to bring him to cnn and then we're
gonna talk about who do we want to be
what's the long-term vision here's what
ted turner built a company for how far
off are we from division okay you know
we're going to go talk to some of the
ogs that used to be there you can't talk
to ted turner right and we're trying to
set up a meeting with ted turner but
he's his health is not doing that well
i'd go talk to some of the original
people what was the vision what did you
guys talk about what was the excitement
what were you trying to do how much do
you see dramatically this thing having
changed i'm going to put a room full of
20 people from the ogog ogs from the 80s
ogs i'm going to say tell us what you
see happened here i want your feedback
what would you do i would hire them as
consultants pay each of these guys 40 50
000 100 000 also be consultants for a
couple months to kind of go back to the
vision and then come out with a new
vision here's what we're going to be
doing and you got to fire and go through
an ugly phase of six months 12 months
and then 2023 you say guys we'll be
competing for the number one spot in
2024 because 2024 is super bowl you know
election is going to be coming back here
we have to be ready for 2024 so 2022 is
the year where you're trading you're
firing you're releasing you're doing all
that stuff so if they do that
the brand is a recognizable brand like
today i'm interested today in buying a
couple media platforms we're having
calls right after this we got to call
matter of fact because i want to buy a
couple
well-known media platforms but i have
plans if i buy there's certain things
that we're going to be doing and we're
not buying those that are doing very
well we're buying brands and we're
talking to brands that are actually
struggling to come in right but they're
massive brands that you know about to
take to the next level so the person
that is currently leading it he sounds
like it's somebody that could pull it up
but we'll see what's going to be
happening there that's what i would do
okay i think you're absolutely right and
you got straight to the how um let me
give you a great company that did this
once before it was harley davidson
harley-davidson was not what it was and
it got bought
and they moved out leadership and the
whole thing was prove it with the
product
prove it with the product and the hog
harley owners group when they proved it
with the product they rejuvenated the
whole thing but they had to prove it and
the product in this case
is and i love the tucker idea is the
on-air talent and the editors that are
balancing the news delivery and i think
if they prove it with the the
product and they do what you're saying
or something very similar to a pat i
think they get there because
you had this beloved brand harley
davidson it was known for low quality
and crap bikes
and yet it was this this legacy of you
know
american transportation
by the way i would have loved to buy cnn
i'm not in a position to do it but i
would have loved to have my uh bought
cnn i would watch it and and uh mix it
up and i would have brought up paul
sankey and to help us out with that uh
but but i think we have paul sankey here
with us yes or no okay can we can we
paul can you hear us paul
i don't know if you can hear us paul can
you see us and hear us
yeah okay fantastic thank you in the
house listen we're excited to have paul
saying here just for the last 15 minutes
here to get some commentary on what's
going on with this
energy all these stories that we're
hearing about paul we appreciate you for
making the time uh paul 30 seconds for
people that don't know your background
if you can kind of share with folks you
made some really
uh uh interesting predictions that at
one point weren't uh popular but you
ended up being right and you've been
doing this for 30 years i think you
first called negative oil prices when
covet hit with your research from sankey
research but 30 seconds background for
audience that doesn't know you
uh i think
you know
the single
moment would be i was the number one
ranked oil analyst on wall street uh for
three straight years when i was working
for deutsche bank so that was in 2010
2011 2012 and then i
joined a boutique wolf research then i i
was briefly at a japanese bank mizuho
and then i started senki research
so um you know you could call me a
former number one analyst on wall street
or something i actually like that i love
you no big deal i like it the way you
say okay so now the audience knows we're
not just talking to anybody this is
somebody that uh in the space respected
by millions and you see him on media
news being interviewed all the time so
paul i'm going to read to you a couple
of things i saw here that seems a little
concerning and then i want to see what
thoughts you have on this so
you know california newsom comes out
talking about how their plans are to ban
uh new gas powered cars by 2030
and they seem very proud about this
decision that they want to do 2035 and
they seem very passionate about this
it's the story i'll read from la times
buy a car in 2035 and you won't have to
decide whether gasoline diesel or
electric you won't have a choice citing
an urgent need to address climate change
while cutting back
on air pollution the california air
resources board voted thursday to
require all new cars and light trucks
sold by 2035 to be what it calls
zero emissions vehicle if automakers
fall short
they could be charged twenty thousand
dollars for non-compliant vehicle the
air resources board said if consumers
don't go along that could cause big
problems under the new rules 35 of new
cars must be zero emissions by 2026 68
by 2030 and 100 by 2035 how realistic is
this when you read a story like this
uh it's not i mean if you listen to the
automakers they're like we don't think
we can do it and if you listen to the
californian energy management they're
saying we're going to have
uh brownouts this weekend coming so you
know they don't have the electricity
system they've managed the energy system
really quite badly
and they've tried this before by the way
in the 80s california had you know
similar very aggressive targets for
electric cars that just completely
bombed and were abandoned the main
problem as far as the automakers are
concerned is they don't think they can
make the cars
and then there's questions as to whether
people will just go to another state to
buy a regular car
um you know they're going to be
limitations on the number of cars the
you know where you buy your car and
whether or not you can cross the border
and crazy stuff like that one very
salient uh
statistic is that there was a study of
california ev owners uh i think for the
three years from
something like 2018 1920
and
20 of bv owners actually went back to a
gas-fired vehicle
so you know
even the guys that are buying the cars
and then changing their mind and wanting
to go back and it was particularly woman
interestingly uh
one of the big demographies that
preferred the gas the bigger car is one
of the things
tend to prefer
and that those tend to be electric so
there's a number of major issues with
this in a in a state frankly that isn't
managing its energy system very well at
all yeah and sh you know you'll hear
pete buddhich you'll hear a lot of these
guys saying look
you know i i saw one senator saying i
drove from michigan to
california and i passed by all these gas
stations and it was great because i
didn't even have to look at them and it
was fantastic you know if you can buy
electric car you don't even have to
worry about this and then a story comes
up from norway yesterday
saying
the electric the lack of power that
they're having to charge a tesla is
costing a hundred dollars which is
pretty much the same as you would be gas
so if the argument is climate change if
the argument is to you know green
let's do that fine that's one argument
but the other argument about it's going
to be cheaper you don't have to worry
about paying gas prices etc etc does
that story hold credibility long term
no it doesn't i mean for a start
everybody is resentful about these
politicians because they seem to make
you know eighty thousand dollars a year
and all be
multi multi millionaires and
obviously the relevance of that is that
everybody knows electric cars are
significantly more expensive than than
the cheapest gas cars so
you know these guys saying hey just buy
an electric car is insulting uh to lower
income people additionally as you know
electric car prices are now rising
because we have significant issues with
the materials that go into these cars
and if you look at them from a cradle to
grave basis that is to say all the way
back to getting
you know the cobalt and the lithium and
everything else and the amount of
material that needs to be moved and the
places that you do that like the congo
like
chile
desperate water problems environmental
problems with the material sourcing
all the way through to the fact that the
vehicle is much heavier and will damage
roads more
uh if the battery breaks it's kind of
terminal you know it's sort of a
15 or 20 000 replacement cost
there's a number of major issues here um
even with these cars being subsidized
they are still very expensive and the
price is rising
for the average person that all they
watch is the news and the media and
that's kind of where they get their
resources like hey it's good for me to
go buy tesla for me to go buy
electric vehicle if i want to be
responsible
you know i i saw some data from roger
mccrat mcgrath i don't know if you saw
that or not where it takes 60 pounds of
cobalt 30 pounds of lithium 130 pounds
of nickel 90 pounds of copper 190 pounds
of graphite
500 pounds of steel aluminum manganese
plastic and other materials to make a
single
battery a single
battery
to produce a single battery how much oil
do we have to use to produce the battery
that we're claiming we're going away
from oil and gas
well yeah and actually it's it's
coal-fired power because a lot of the
processing of almost all the processing
of lithium copper
all of these materials firstly the
processing is very dirty business it's
typically done in china
and as you know china is 75 coal-fired
power additionally for example in the
case of solar
80 of poly silicon comes from china and
that's there's considerable evidence
that that's made using forced labor with
weaker muslims
so you know this whole you know that's
uh i'm i think electric cars are great i
think for households with two cars they
should have one electric
for short distances i believe 90 of us
vehicle trips are less than 10 miles
and that's it is more efficient on that
basis but as you as you also know you
can't drive long distances
without having to recharge for a much
longer time in an electric car so
people i think want the freedom of being
able to drive a long distance when they
want to even though they don't do it
very often and i i don't see how well
these things are going to do
additionally
their performance is is debatable
firstly in very extreme weather extreme
heat and particularly extreme cold
and furthermore if the grid goes down
which happens in extreme cold
uh or extreme heat then you can't charge
it at all
so i just don't think that the
projections of sales of evs are going to
be i think they'll be they'll grow a lot
but i don't think they're going to be
anything like what people assume uh you
know in their models for example nobody
models that 20 of california drivers
switch away from an ev having bought one
it's funny you say that because elon
musk he was asked the question i think
yesterday or day before and i'm sure you
saw this
he said realistically i think we need
oil and gas in the short term because
otherwise civilization will crumble he
told reuters
one of the biggest challenges the world
has ever faced in the transition to
sustainable energy into a sustainable
economy that will take some decades to
complete obviously that is now what
california and other politicians want to
hear but let me let me talk a little bit
about ask you on
the british household energy bills to
jump 80 percent to over 4 000
dollars a year
when you see a number like that you know
4 80 average 41.88 a year from october
the regulator said on friday plunging
millions of household into fuel poverty
and businesses into jeopardy on those
unless the government steps in the rise
will have a massive impact on households
across britain and other another
increase was likely in january as
russia's move to throttle european
supplies drives wholesale gas prices to
record highs this is a catastrophe
britain's leading consumer rights
champion martin luther lewis said
warning that people would die if they
refused to cook food or heat their homes
this winter what do you see when you see
numbers like that
well in september of 21 before the
ukraine russia situation i wrote about
the gas situation in europe and said
that there would be more people that die
in europe from
heat poverty than will die from covid
uh over the coming years and you know
unfortunately i think there's a good
chance of that so the numbers that you
mentioned were to keep it very rounded
uh
in past years the average household bill
was about a thousand pounds which would
be about one thousand two hundred
dollars a year
uh that set as you said to rise likely
to five or six thousand pounds
uh the average british income the
average british income is 33 000 pounds
and so of course whilst it becomes very
expensive for someone who's on the
average income you know going from one
over 33 to to five over 33
um
for those who are on low income you know
it's extremely extremely concerning and
the government is going to have to step
in the problem is you know the
governments don't have a whole lot of
money so it's very tough for them the
big concern is that i think over 90
percent of uk households heat their
homes with gas
and there's also the additional
potential for just outright gas
shortages particularly because it's all
heating use
um
you know if we get a very cold winter
which we don't know i suspect there'll
be very cold snaps based on recent
weather volatility by the way 87 percent
of you u.s households have air
conditioning
one percent of german houses have air
conditioning so the summer that we've
seen here is not that relevant
i don't know that that's insane
what i'm saying is that you have a
massive peak of demand in winter and we
haven't seen that yet now i suspect that
putin is gaming this into winter to
scare everybody
and may actually be prepared to make
peace in ukraine nobody's saying that
but i just i think it's an outside
chance
but it's it is extremely concerning
now if they get through this winter
putin putin's leverage will collapse
right because they've shown they don't
need russian gas so there's a
significant risk for him
that if europe can pull this off
suddenly he just screwed his you know
his gas prom position in europe which
was
dominant now becomes worth you know
almost nothing because they worked out
how to not use russian gas and obviously
this winter is the highest risk winter
paul what are your thoughts on what's
going to happen with everything that we
hear on media how much of it is true
with what's going on with oil prices
you know gas prices are going down you
know it's going to keep going down with
the policies they're coming up with well
you know if russia does what it does
it's going to go up well this is just
temporary the gas prices are going to go
down before midterms there's so many
it's so loud and nobody knows who to
trust who to listen to you've been in
this game for 30 years
you know you were the number one expert
in this topic for three years what do
you see going on and who do you really
trust when you hear all these different
information coming at us
well i think the administration realized
that to get inflation down they could
see that the largest component of
inflation was basically gasoline pump
prices which as you know is also a very
publicized price right everybody can see
the gasoline price every time they drive
down the street and so it becomes a very
uh significant issue now
actually in terms of share of income
gasoline prices haven't been that high
and you have to remember that where
we're screaming about four dollars a
gallon and five dollars a gallon in
europe they're paying 10 and 11 a gallon
for gasoline crazy um and obviously as a
result they drive much smaller cars and
much shorter distances but the
government realized they had to bring
down the oil price and it really only
has one tool and that's the strategic
petroleum reserve which is really
reserved for emergencies but without
there being an emergency which was last
november there was no emergency they
started pulling down the strategic
reserve in order to try and get oil
prices down and that was pretty clearly
uh trying to work into the midterms a
lower oil price
because politicians are just obsessed
that high gasoline prices are you know
are going to get you voted out of office
they then switched up oh by the way at
the time the energy secretary
granholm
was asked you know when she announced
the november release of oil some clever
journalists said by the way you know she
said we're releasing 50 million barrels
and some clever journalists said by the
way how much oil does the us use a day
and she was like
i don't have that in front of me but
i'll get back to you it's like oh my god
she doesn't even know how much we use
so that was pretty horrific and um but
anyway then as of the beginning of
summer as prices got really lively the
us has been pushing the government has
been pushing one million barrels a day
of uh strategic petroleum reserve it's
going down at the fastest rate in its
history one million barrels a day on u.s
demand is about 20 million dollars a day
so it's a huge um
a huge pressure on on the downside of
the market and what's concerning is they
can't do that forever obviously because
it's coming from strategic plan reserves
um what will happen when it stops in
october right before the midterms and
will they have to rebuild it and in
amongst all that that extra million
barrels a day firstly is outraged people
because a lot of it was exported because
the us refiners don't particularly want
that specific type of oil that they have
stored
um
you know so there's there's the fact
that we actually exported our emergency
reserves is kind of dumb
and then you know do we do we rebuild
them
in all of that the oil price really as
of today is still 95 dollars a barrel so
you put that much pressure on the market
and you've only got it down to 95. and
then finally within the past week or so
saudi has said basically that they're
going to defend a hundred dollars a
barrel
ish
um
they weren't specific about the number
but they basically said we're watching
the oil price and if it goes much lower
we'll start cutting production
so all of these things are you know
implying that we're going to have very
high oil prices for quite uh several
years i would say and as we really
reference we don't see electric vehicles
and
the whole so-called energy transition
really making a very big difference in
fact
we now talk about the energy regression
because you'll see that global coal
demand is at an all-time high highs this
particularly europe but also obviously
china in the u.s even
scrambled to
replace gas with coal which obviously is
moving in totally the wrong direction
from an emissions point of view
paul can you just expand on that a
little bit more the energy regression uh
if i'm not mistaken germany is now
burning coal people in poland are
scrambling to get firewood i mean
europe doesn't have the energy right now
russia is flaring natural gas so they
have huge leverage i mean what is this
winner going to look like because from
the outset it seems like it's gonna be
absolutely catastrophic for the eu
yeah normal or cold
it's going to be bad and it's going to
involve rationing and what you do is you
basically shut down industry
you know so you shut down major
consumers major single source consumers
of energy germany has huge chemical i
think the single biggest
chemical processing facility in the
world is in germany
it has a lot of heavy industry and the
whole industrial complex is built on
russian cheap russian gas
so there's a major economic problem
obviously what people what the
government should do if they get their
act together is you protect individuals
you know so you then
you then you know make sure that the
homes get get the energy while industry
is starved so essentially it looks it
looks very bad economically in a normal
to cold winter scenario and they might
just pull it off if winter comes in
in warm which could happen you also get
the id the fact that
you can get a triple cold winter which
would be cold in in the u.s cold cold in
north america cold in europe and cold in
northeast asia all of which have um
you know cold winters when it's cold and
need energy to heat uh you can get a
situation where you have the opposite so
a triple warm winter and frankly years
ago i met george bush's chief of staff
and he was saying that bush was so upset
about hurricane katrina that the two of
them traveled to see uh
to see the national weather center to
work out what on earth was going on with
weather forecasting and he said what
they learned is that the weather
forecasts
are very very accurate for the next 24
hours and pretty good for the next three
days
for the next three days
and after that they don't have a clue
and um you know we do try to watch
weather patterns and stuff and glo you
know with global flows but at the moment
there's been this extraordinary omega
effect uh which has been this
extraordinary hot weather
in europe but
china is currently having the biggest
heatwave
seen in history ever recorded right now
and so that's also serving to reduce
hydropower which they're dependent on
china's already water short and i'm sure
you've seen the pictures of the yangtze
and other huge rivers that have dried up
they have a major problem i mean and at
the moment it's staying hot through
september
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
weather impacts that leave plenty of
room for concern and we're very
concerned about china not that we don't
deeply dislike the communist party there
but you know we would like to see
ultimately become more democratic but um
they have huge problems going into their
party congress so they have a huge party
congress one in every five years coming
up in october when they'll be voting for
shi
and we'll see how they do with the
economy being so bad
china's economy being so bad and energy
demand being so low has probably been
one of the biggest surprises of 2022 and
there's been plenty of surprises
interesting paul appreciate you so much
for coming in and giving insight uh
it's it's always great to hear from you
and and your perspective
uh i think sometimes the the world when
they watch news they don't know who to
believe it's always good to get a
different perspective for someone like
you once again thanks so much for uh
being on the podcast
yeah folks to to learn more about paul
sankey
tyler if we can put the link below
sankeyresearch.com
go follow him on twitter and follow his
content and his website we're going to
put that in the chat as well as a
description for people to find him gank
if you enjoyed today's podcast
give it a subscribe button and a thumbs
up today we're doing a vault i'm about
to head over to the diplomat because
we're about to have a couple thousand
people that are gonna come to the
diplomat to be with us at the vault with
chas palminteri uh kevin connolly robert
kiyosaki
andy fast out the former cfo
of enron yeah who went to jail he was
willing to talk is going to talk at the
event which is very exciting don't
forget about the biggest name who's
going to be tom elworth
and others so cannot wait to see those
of you guys that are tuning in that are
going to be at the vault with us for
everybody else we will not be doing
another podcast this week we will see
you guys next week possibly next week
sometime take care everybody have a
great weekend bye bye bye
you